welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
massive mma news broke friday afternoon
when the official ufc twitter account
announced israel otasania will defend
his middleweight title against alex
pereira the bout will headline ufc 281
on november 12th in madison square
garden kamaru usman's brother muhammad
will fight this saturday in the ultimate
fighters season 30 finale the
heavyweight bout between usman and zac
paga will be on the main card for ufc on
espn 40. in video obtained from mma
junkie usman spoke about his experience
on the show and how he stayed mentally
ready to reach the finals oh man it was
uh it was all of the above
it was enjoyable i mean you get free
food you get to order the best foods you
can order whatever you can think of
organic steak put it on the list you
order it they'll get it to you and uh
yeah it was it was nerve-racking you
know you know you might potentially
fight with your roommates you know
you're sleeping in the same room with
these guys that you're gonna fight
you're keeping one eye open
uh you know it's just the nerves the
mind the process you know you lose
you're out you win you keep going it was
a
it was really a test of will it was test
of will it was test of your heart your
determination and uh i just stayed
focused i just stayed true to myself i
kept my game plan no matter who tried to
interrupt that distract me everything i
just stayed focused man and uh i'm just
very very blessed to be here
muhammad is looking to join his brother
kamaru as a winner of the popular show
and spoke about what it's like to be so
attached to his brother in the sport i
love it he's an usman it's our last name
i'm here because of my brother for the
aspect of he started fighting before me
muhammad did make sure to make it clear
that he has earned everything and he
hasn't gotten any special advantages
despite being the younger brother of the
welterweight champion i had to put in
work to get here fighting is fighting
it's not oh kamaru's your brother now
let's just push you up here you're in
the ultimate fighter finale you don't
have to fight these two hard monsters
that are coming in at 265 pounds to be
here we'll put you here because your
brother is kamara usman that's false
everything about fighting is yourself
that's why i love it so much because as
much as people speak about my brother
that's why i love it because i'm still
the one that has to go out there and
compete and have to fight and have to
win for you guys to even be up here and
talk crap to me and tell me about my
brother if i don't win i'm not even
getting up here and looking at you guys
colby covington continues to win big
outside of the octagon earlier in the
week covington made headlines for
placing seventh in florida's biggest
poker tournament ever and just two days
later he took the top spot in event 22
at the seminole hard rock poker open
with the win covington takes home a
trophy and a cool 25
875 dollars of prize money speaking to
seminolehardrockpokeropen.com
covington talked about finishing seventh
earlier in the week and the first place
finish
i wanted to come back and prove that
wasn't just a fluke and show that i
could play with the best players in the
world it's a surreal feeling it's been a
long journey to finally get a trophy
here at seminole hard rock this is my
home casino and i love playing here
covington also shared how his experience
in the octagon correlates to success on
the poker table luckily for me i fought
at the highest levels on pay-per-view
and in front of sold-out arenas like
madison square garden i'm used to the
nerves and i know how to channel them
and use them in the right way i don't
ever get emotional when playing cards or
fighting and just playing my best game
every time i come out
news has been swirling that a
lightweight bout between top contenders
dustin poirier and michael chandler is
close to being finalized ariel helwani
first broke the news with espn's brett
akamoto providing further details
talks are ongoing for a huge lightweight
fight between dustin poirier and michael
chandler date is still tbd ker sources
chandler's preference is december
poirier has made it clear he's been
ready to fight date being worked out now
akamoto followed that up with another
tweet talks around poirier chandler
could result in a fight.msg in november
as reported by ariel helwani sources
also tell me poirier's side is pushing
for the non-title fight to be five
rounds again chandler prefers a december
date nothing done yet still ongoing
poirier hinted with a tweet of his own
that the news isn't far from the truth
simply saying five rounds
if the bout were to take place dustin
poirier would open up as the betting
favorite draftkings put up odds of the
proposed fight with poirier as a -155
favorite and chandler that plus 135
underdog
anthony smith joined michael bisping on
the believe you me podcast to shed some
light on the broken leg he suffered last
saturday at ufc 277 smith told bisping
that despite media reports his leg
wasn't broken from a kick inflicted by
magomedoncliffe and that it was a freak
accident
i threw this hard overhand and it was
just a little short and he came back
with a hard leg kick and my whole leg
went numb from the knee down it was only
like 20 seconds 15 seconds it came back
pretty quick but i didn't really think
anything of it just hit a weird nerve
and your leg goes numb shortly after
that we got tangled up you know how it
gets with the opposite stances your feet
get tangled up sometimes and i went to
step back with my left foot and it's
like wasn't anything there it was weird
right before he kicked me and my leg
went numb i was stepping on his foot so
we were having that lead foot battle and
it happened twice i stepped on his foot
and he pulled it out and then it drug my
body forward and my ankle kind of went
all funny and right after that he banged
that inside kick real hard i know in the
media or whatever it's been reported it
was from a kick it's 100 not it's not
from a kick it's just [ __ ] [ __ ] luck
smith was able to back his claim by
sharing the opinion of jeffrey davidson
the ufc's chief medical advisor
it's not like a typical combat sports
break it's a weird break dr davidson
said in 29 years he's never seen it in
combat sports apparently it's in my
ankle but it's a continuation of my leg
bone
mmafighting.com's mike heck interviewed
jorge mosbidal in savannah georgia prior
to mozville's promotions icon fc4 event
during the discussion heck asked
mazvidal about his thoughts on the
upcoming ufc 279 bout between
welterweight's nate diaz and hamza
chimaya mozvidal shared his belief that
chemiev is being oversold and gave
credit to diaz the man he won the bmf
title over i don't really think hamza is
as good as they say he is i'm more of a
c than believe and i haven't seen
anything that makes me a believer in
this guy yet i personally would love to
break his face i think hamza probably
wins but i can see nate putting him away
in rounds four or five because hanzo
doesn't have that gas tank he doesn't
have that experience and i think he gets
two in the moment where he's wasting
energy doing stupid [ __ ] nate is going
to conserve all that energy and get in
his face when it counts i think hamza
should win but i won't be surprised if
nate stops his ass shimayev clearly
heard the comments from mozvidal and
poked fun at the bmf champ on twitter
wake up buddy at game red fighter
in an effort to connect their fans with
one of their biggest stars the ufc
posted a video of patty pimblett talking
about premier league soccer ahead of the
league's return in the video pimlick
gave his predictions for the season and
not surprisingly gave the top spot to
his reds from liverpool
top six yeah liverpool first then we're
gonna run patricia city second
spurs third and then i don't know
chelsea or arsenal four michael chelsea
bottle it all of our arsenal fifth
united sixth
salad or nunes one of the two
[Music]
that's tyler morton's quality
that he's i'm trying i think he's almost
like half not in the first team because
he's not on the first team obviously i'm
just going to say i have the elias but i
have these i didn't the first team
people know he is but definitely have of
breakout season this year he released
quality
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you